refugees lining up in front of a
registration Center in Berlin much like
any other morning since the migration
crisis began but the typical chatter
above documents and waiting times has
died out here people are only talking
about the Paris attacks well ha that was
really awful it has nothing to do with
humanity and one thing is for sure it
has nothing to do with Islam they're all
extremists can i lke thurs four weeks
ago Halle and her husband maudelle left
their homeland in Syria with their
children they wanted to be free from the
constant fear and terror let me know
what did when my husband told me about
it yesterday I was utterly shocked we
left her home and came to Europe to be
safe and now this and there's in wondon
it off him LaVon okie does eschew this
we are very concerned this is really bad
for me and my family now we are even a
little bit scared here where we thought
we would be safe yeah you moanin almost
luckily neither lurgy lucky day for me
what happened in France has sadly been a
regular occurrence in Syria for the past
four years yet the Syrians are quite
empathetic even though still living in
an atmosphere of constant terror a noir
shows us a video from his hometown of
Douma the city has been the target of
numerous bombs and airstrikes just two
weeks ago over 70 people were killed in
an attack yet here people have lit
candles for the victims of Paris without
a result of ours though I'm very sad
about what happened in France everyone
in the Arab world should be grateful to
the Europeans for all they are doing to
help the refugees at least they're doing
something for the refugees not like some
Arab countries blood la rabia here
myself domino but for how long the
refugee sense the fear that is creeping
into german society but their worries
are still focused on the loved ones they
left behind
a kid a kid I'm worried I'm very worried
of course for my son jennifer and my
whole family back in Syria hello mayors
oh no number holla this man is from the
city of rocker a stronghold of Islamic
state since French air rage there on
Sunday morning he has been unable to
reach his cousin